today on the Matt wall show death
tourism is a growing industry in the
United States and it's as horrifying as
it sounds we'll talk about it also Biden
stumbled and fumbled his way through the
State of the Union Address much of the
speech was difficult to translate from
whatever language he was speaking the
rest was full of lies and Trump accuses
DeSantis of being a groomer all of
Trump's attacks on the scientists have
failed so far will this one be any
different plus Joy Reid on MSNBC says
the left has achieved total victory in
the culture war is she right and if so
does that mean she'll stop finally you
know playing the victim card unlikely
but we'll talk about that and much more
today on the Matt Walsh
[Music]
if you need a gift for Valentine's Day
well then you need genucel skin care for
the first time ever every order at
genucel.com from now until Valentine's
Day includes a free Beauty Box with two
luxury gifts there they just introduced
their new microbiome moisturizer which
uses the power of probiotics to Target
skin redness pesky wrinkles Fine Lines
patchy blotches and other signs of
premature aging these are the same
probiotics that are in your yogurt as it
turns out probiotics are not just good
for digestion they can have the same
nourishing benefits on your skin you can
see results in 12 hours or get your
money back guaranteed my talent manager
Tessa uses genucel under eye treatment
to help get rid of the bags under eyes
that she claims are my fault for working
her so hard right now you can get
genucel's most popular package for 70
off as well as your two free luxury
gifts visit genucel.com Walsh and get 70
off with your free gifts use code wall
should check out to have this applied to
your account that's genucel.com Welsh
genucel.com Welsh
I am not going to begin the show today
with an analysis of the State of the
Union Address it's just not that
important this is a reality that is hard
for the political pundit class to accept
besides I think there are better ways of
ascertaining the actual State of the
Union in fact of all the ways listening
to a stump speech from the president is
going to give you probably the least
accurate impression of how things are
actually going
instead I'll point you towards a report
published this week by The Daily Mail
which reveals the startling details of
the burgeoning suicide tourism industry
The Daily Mail reports quote Oregon has
become America's first death tourism
destination where terminally ill people
from Texas and other states that have
outlawed assisted suicide have started
traveling to get their hands on a deadly
cocktail of drugs to end their lives
dailymail.com can reveal in the liberal
Bastion of Portland at least one Clinic
has started receiving out-of-staters who
have less than six months to live and
meet the other strict requirements of
the state's death With Dignity law Dr
Nicholas gideonis the director of the
end of life choices in Oregon recently
told a panel that he was advising
terminally ill non-residents on
traveling to the state to end their
lives despite a legal gray area
now sidebar one thing to note here is
that the the phrase strict requirements
should be taken with an enormous grain
of salt this is the way it always starts
right we we begin with the evil thing in
small doses with lots of alleged
limitations and strict requirements they
say until little by little those
requirements are loosened and the
limitations are eroded and soon you're
providing assisted suicide to people who
suffer from conditions like homelessness
as they are in Canada
every country that now euthanizes people
who aren't even terminally ill started
by only euthanizing the terminally ill
okay this is the way it always goes the
process is inevitable it's a river that
flows in One Direction and One Direction
only
now it's not hard to see why an assisted
suicide regime if it gains a foothold
will always grow more expansive over
time and partly it's just the nature of
the left's agenda this is a cancer that
grows and progresses and infects other
parts of the body and that's simply what
cancer does
and in this case in particular we can
see how the principles of euthanasia
once accepted will lead to certain
conclusions inevitably
assisted suicide
Presents Death as a legitimate treatment
option it puts doctors in the position
of directly killing their patients and
charging them for the privilege of being
killed
medicalizing and monetizing death just
one more way of doing it it says that
death is a medically valid strategy so
you know why suffer When Death can give
you an escape from all that suffering
this is the euthanasia sales pitch
if we as a society will accept this
sales pitch for the terminally ill
there's no coherent reason to reject it
in every other case
I mean we're all terminally ill after
all we all suffer from the medical
condition known as mortality
our days are numbered and the older you
get the closer death approaches if you
are say 75 years old
you'll probably be dead within a decade
statistically whether you have a
terminal illness or not so I mean why
drag it out when the magic pill can give
you an easy exit today
see by the logic of assisted suicide if
someone is suffering greatly even if the
suffering is only psychological rather
than physical there's no reason to force
them to continue living with it
especially because they're just going to
eventually die anyway
this is the logic behind the greatly
expanded euthanasia programs in Canada
and some European countries and places
like Colombia and elsewhere it always
starts with limitations
and then ends up here and this is not
just with euthanasia this is with
literally everything on the left's
agenda and if there's anyone out there
who still needs this to be explained to
them then uh then I mean it's hopeless I
don't know I don't know
it shouldn't need to be explained all
you need to do is look at the culture
and see
for a fact back to the Daily Mail
says quote out of state residents must
be able to spend at least 15 days in
Oregon to process the paperwork which
requires sign-offs from two doctors and
Witnesses before the administering the
Fatal dose themselves says the Clinic's
website Dr gadionis and the clinic
operate in the legal Gray Zone the state
last year agreed to extend access to
doctor assisted suicide to
out-of-staters but this is not expected
to be codified into law until later this
year but America's first death tourism
destination throws up tough legal
questions for family members who may
help a loved one reach the state from a
prohibitionist state they could face
arrest or even be prosecuted in their
home state as a result for critics
Oregon's Nation death tourism industry
and efforts to create another in Vermont
show how the U.S is on a slippery slope
to following in Canada's footsteps where
LAX rules have allowed people with so
little less hearing loss to be
euthanized while U.S assisted suicide
rules are comparatively strict and help
some desperately sick people end their
Agony critics say they also devalue
human life and make deadly drugs a
solution for the infirm I'm disabled and
even those who are cash strapped or feel
like a burden
well that's exactly what it does it's
what it's designed to do
and you know I have to say
there is something so viscerally
horrifying about the idea of filling out
paperwork to die
and it's almost difficult to put into
words it's like it's a uniquely modern
horror it's just it's it's the
combination of the worst things about
modern society the combination of
paperwork
waiting rooms
and and then death and it's it's it's
depressing and despair-inducing in a way
that evades description just like
imagining someone in this kind of
sterile waiting room with the
fluorescent lights filling out a bunch
of paperwork you know on a little
clipboard
and then sitting there waiting to go
back and die is just uh or to talk to a
doctor about
being given the drugs to die
it's again viscerally horrifying
as always our efforts to sanitize ugly
things only make those ugly things even
uglier
and here when I say ugly things I don't
mean death specifically death is is ugly
in the sense that it's scary and often
painful yet fundamentally death is also
a natural process it's part of life it's
a kind of a our death is a is a
passenger that we carry with us it's
always it's always there
so when I say ugly I'm referring to
Suicide suicide is an ugly thing one one
of the ugliest things
and that's what we're trying to sanitize
and medicalize with euthanasia it's it's
uh among other things dishonest because
it lies to the patient
first by calling him a patient
lies to him about what he's doing allows
him to lie to himself
I mean think about it this way
if somebody needs euthanasia to kill
themselves
uh if they wouldn't kill themselves if
not for euthanasia because of course you
know suicide is one of those things that
is a it's an option available to
everyone all the time uh it's something
that anyone can do even painlessly they
shouldn't it's a terrible thing
but it's not something that you strictly
speaking need a doctor for to facilitate
so if somebody does feel like they in
order to do this they need the doctor to
give them the the poison pills
well
that tells us that there's something
about suicide that this person
recognizes as wrong
and so they turn to the doctor-assisted
version of suicide to paper over those
rough edges
because it makes suicide seem palatable
to people who otherwise apparently would
choose to live
this is this is the whole point of it
really and it's well it's what makes it
such a Sinister evil
now
as repellent as all this may be
we should also keep in mind it's not as
unique in this country as we might like
to imagine death tourism comes in
different forms
a number of states have already set
themselves up as abortion destinations
Connecticut just recently passed a law
and joined California and New York as
abortion sanctuaries offering to fly
pregnant women in kill their babies and
have them home in a few days ready to
get back to work some of these same
States California Minnesota in
particular are also declaring themselves
sanctuaries for child castration
parents can bring their gender confused
children have them castrated sterilized
and then back to school in no time
pretty soon these states will have their
own travel agents offering package deals
for the whole family
you know come to Vermont we'll abort
your baby castrate your son and
euthanize Grandpa then you can all hit
the slopes this is all death tourism in
one form or another perhaps we might
call it culture of death tourism a tour
through the culture of death and all its
Myriad Horrors and all the ways and
wishes to devour you
because that's all the culture of death
wants to do or can do
you know it offers
nothing but nothingness
it gives nothing in return for the
everything it takes from you
which really is a bargain that should be
very easy to turn down
now let's get to our headlines
Pure Talk is the antidote to woke
wireless companies it's proudly veteran
owned employs a us-based customer
service team and absolutely refuses to
spend money on fake news networks not to
mention Pure Talk service is fantastic
they're one of the largest networks in
the country you can get blazing fast
data talk and text for as low as 30
bucks a month that's probably half of
what you're paying for you know if
you're Verizon at T or T-Mobile Pure
Talk the no contract Wireless company is
the only Wireless company offer a 100
money back guarantee on your first month
don't get locked into a multi-year
contract with huge penalties switch over
to Pure Talk in as little as 10 minutes
while keeping your phone and your phone
number go to puretalk.com enter promo
code Walsh to save 50 off your first
month that's puretalk.com promo code
walls pure talk it's simply smarter
Wireless
so we're going a little bit of a little
out of order here I guess because I'm
saving the State of the Union stuff for
the end for the daily cancellation where
it belongs and um there I'll give my
full take on the address and this
particular address and also address the
State of Union address in general and
it'll be very exciting I promise well
maybe not but we're going to do it
anyway there's one part of speech that
won't be in that segment but I can't
neglect to mention so we'll touch on it
here Biden invited the parents of Tyree
Nichols to the speech and then use them
as a platform to launch into a thing
about racist cops which of course is not
only just abhorrent and gratuitous uh
you know to use these grieving parents
that way is is I mean it's not at all
surprising coming from Biden the
Democrats
um but it is uh it's a
sick and depraved thing to do and and
also even more baseless than usual given
that Nichols was killed by black cops
from a department run by a female uh
black police chief so there's just as
we've covered there's there's no racism
angle here at all which is why even
though Biden brought the parents in
because he like he had to and Camille
Harris went to the funeral which is
another completely gratuitous and
disgusting thing that people that the
politicians do you know going to a
funeral of someone you didn't know I
mean it's one thing if this is something
that this is a some sort of dignitary or
head of state or something like that
um
and then a politician attends the
funeral
but an average citizen going to the
it's like you you are blatantly
politicized your very presence is meant
to politicize the funeral of this person
so yeah they're doing all that but at
the same time the media has
basically moved on from Tyree Nichols
completely
if you think back to George Floyd when
we were a couple weeks off from George
Floyd they were it was still very much
in the headlines and would remain there
for months uh tiger Nichols have already
moved on because
although they look for this racial angle
it's it's it's not an it's it's not
convincing to people they haven't been
able to make that case they can't re
they can try to racialize it and they
did try but it fell flat and so they
kind of moved on
um but
it was this part of speech uh that
started with Tyler Nichols that really
uh stood out to me and here it is
most of us in here
have never had to have the talk
the talk that brown and black parents
have had to have with their children Bo
Hunter Ashley and my children
I never had to have to talk with him
I never had to tell them if a police
officer pulls you over turn your
interior lights on right away
don't reach for your license
keep your hands on the steering wheel
imagine having to worry like that every
single time
your kid got in a car
I mean first of all there are a lot of
talks with Hunter Biden that he probably
should have had and and he didn't but
this whole thing about about the talk I
mean we hear this all the time now about
oh The Talk The Talk The Talk that black
parents have to have with their precious
children and no no other family has to
have the talk you know all the black
families they know about the talk oh the
talk
oh shut up what what do you talk and
everyone you know then and then all the
all these stupid white people go along
with it oh you're right I've never heard
of that talk I can't imagine I can't
imagine having to hear that talk about
how to handle uh getting pulled over I
can't imagine oh will you stop
it's nonsense okay black families are
not the only ones who have that talk
okay it's just that I had to talk I
remember that talk from my dad we didn't
make a big deal out of it it wasn't like
uh they didn't need to be emotional
dramatic music playing in the background
it wasn't this it didn't traumatize me
to hear the talk but it's like every
competent parents has this talk with
their kid when they first start driving
I can remember it I can remember it uh
when I got a license and I was able to
drive on my own for the first time and I
remember my dad explained to me if you
get pulled over
uh make sure to listen what the officer
says say you know yes officer no officer
keep your hands in view just comply with
whatever they say
um if you don't agree with the ticket
don't argue with the police officer
Nothing's Gonna Come of that well you
argue it in court
that that's and that was it that was
that was the talk
that my dad said to me and when my kids
start driving I'll say the same thing to
them what's the other option it's like
you're teaching your kid to drive are
you not going to say anything about what
happens if they get pulled over
it's not a big deal
of course you can have that talk
why is that a traumatic terrible thing
that you would have to explain you
should explain that to your kid
and it's not because we're excusing
police brutality or anything like that
or being boot lickers of the state okay
it's just
when you're when you're having an
interaction with it with uh with a
police officer
because you've allegedly you know
committed some sort of infraction like
speeding
it just makes sense to not
uh
exacerbate the situation
or make it worse than it needs to be
it's like you you the goal here because
because you are having interaction with
it with a an agent of the state who's
armed and carrying a gun all the rest of
it so the goal here is to make that
interaction as simple and quick as
possible
and if you if again if you don't agree
with something if you don't think you
should have been pulled over if you
think that he was wrong about this or
that then that's you go to court it's
there's you're not going to have any
success arguing with him he's already
made his decision
so then that's what court is for that's
why we have that
that's one of the advantages of living
in an allegedly civilized society where
we have courts you go to them and you
argue with them about it
yes you should have this talk everyone
has this talk so shut up about the talk
you know it's this um
and again what's what's so wrong like
why is that a problem
the fact that you have to have that talk
with your kids
it's this whole concept of a victim
blaming right where it's it's somehow
wrong to give people advice on how to
avoid becoming a victim
that's good advice to give
and and you also know something else too
that
no
nearly every alleged police brutality
video that we see
and many of them I say alleged because
many of these police brutality videos in
reality when you have the full context
you realize that it's actually not
police brutality but sometimes it is I
mean Tyree Nichols almost everyone
agrees I I haven't I would say everyone
I haven't heard anyone that said that's
saying otherwise so it from what I've
seen everyone agrees that um
the cops in that case went like several
miles over the line wherever the line is
they're way way over it
um because they're holding him back and
beating him and it looks like I talked
at the time it looks like it's some sort
of gang beating it doesn't it doesn't
resemble law enforcement at all and
that's why they're they were all
arrested and charged you know with uh
with murder
um so there are times when the police
brutality is where it's legitimately
police police brutality but
in nearly all these cases
okay
in nearly all of them not all of them
but nearly all
it starts with someone resisting arrest
okay and what that now does that mean
that just because you resist arrest it
gives the cops the right to kill you no
okay does that mean that every single
person who resists arrest should be
killed no
that's not the point
the point is simply that when you make
that decision
to start getting aggressive with the
cops you have radically increased your
chances of something terrible happening
to you so why do it
now you can respond all you want and by
saying well I should be able to arrest
to resist arrest without being killed I
should be able to do that in America we
should be able to resist arrest and not
be killed by the cops
I mean sure maybe in some cases depends
on what we mean by resisting arrest I
guess it depends on how long this goes
on and what exactly you're doing and you
know are you resisting arrests like the
Rashad Brooks case in Atlanta where he
steals the cops weapon in the process
and gets killed
um
yo that's one form and uh and then or is
it is it like a Tyree Nichols thing
but regardless
okay
you have still like you can talk all you
want about house here this is how it
should be
yeah you know I can make an argument
that I should be able to
walk through the inner city
you know in the middle of the night
waving a stack of cash in the air
and skipping along and singing about how
I have a wad of cash and I'm waving it
in the air I should and I should be able
to do that
without without getting assaulted or
killed or robbed I should
like in a in you know in a in a in a
country where everyone is good and
decent and nothing bad happens I should
be able to do that I should be able to
skip down the middle of the the you know
West Side Baltimore
waving a wad of cash in the air and no
harm should come to me I should be able
to
but I don't live I don't happen to live
in a universe where that's the reality
unfortunately
okay and so it's it's important to tell
people like yeah maybe you should be
able to but you can't so don't do that
there are just realities about the world
we live in that you should understand
and you should respond accordingly you
should operate within the boundaries of
reality as it exists
not the boundaries of this fantasy world
you wished you lived in and you should
do that for your own sake so you don't
die and this is an important thing to
explain to people and it's something
that your parents ought to explain to
you
so back to police brutality
you start resisting arrest
whether or not you should be able to do
that without getting killed is
irrelevant
you've greatly increased your chance of
getting injured or killed by doing that
why do it what could you possibly gain
from doing it no one ever asks this
question we're not allowed to ask it
in every video where someone's resisting
arrest and then gets killed even if it
was an unjustified killer we're not
allowed to ask like what was your plan
here what did you think was why do it
what think this through for a second
best case scenario you resist arrest
okay that's so let's do the plan here
step one resist arrest uh what are the
other steps
do you think you'll resist arrest and
then they'll just say oh never mind
we're not going to arrest you at all oh
you don't oh you don't want to be
arrested well never mind just go about
your I didn't realize you didn't want to
be well go ahead go ahead then never
mind
that's not gonna happen so like best
case scenario
is your resist arrest and maybe you
escape
unharmed but then now you're a fugitive
and you've just added a whole bunch of
charges that you didn't have before and
so now you're going to go to jail for
longer when they do catch you than you
did before uh more likely you're not
going to escape and so even maybe they
they get a they get you you know to get
a hold of you and they detain you
and you're not injured but now you have
more charges than you would have had
before so best case scenario resisting
arrest you take a situation where you
were in trouble and now you're in a lot
more trouble
that's the best case scenario
there is no other that's that's as good
as it can get for you so why do it
it is just it's like it's utterly
self-destructive Behavior
and every time it's like this it's
ridiculous that we're not allowed to
point this out no one ever asks
why are you doing it
yeah these are all talks
and and because like none of us are
allowed to have this talk in public it's
so deeply offensive to bring this up so
maybe parents yeah you should probably
be having this talk with your kids it's
a good idea whether your kids are black
or white or any other color this is a
talk you should be having with them
all right
um
daily wire reports this former president
Donald Trump
promoted baseless claims on social media
Tuesday that accused Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis of grooming underage girls
with alcohol
Trump's latest attack against the
Florida governor who recently won
re-election of Florida with a historic
19.4 uh Point blowout
comes after Trump claimed last week that
DeSantis begged him for an endorsement
in 2018 and that there were tears coming
down from his eyes I'm sure there were
why why makeup lies that no one yeah
Trump DeSantis went to Trump crying and
saying will you endorse me
all right Trump promoted a post that
showed a grainy photograph of someone
that is alleged to be a DeSantis
standing next to several women at a
party who appear to be roughly the same
age
the post claim here is Rhonda San
Clemente's grooming high school girls
with alcohol as a teacher Trump promoted
the post on a social media channel
writing that's not wrong is it he would
never do such a thing
the New York Times previously reported
the photo was published by a Blog drawn
by a Democrat Super Pac and that two
former female students said parties that
the Santa's attendant took place after
they had graduated
okay
so Trump's latest line of attack is that
DeSantis once took a picture with some
former students that's it that's that's
literally all
um that's that's what they have they
have Trump they have Santa's standing
with some former students
in a picture
and then Trump basically directly
accuses him of grooming them with
alcohol which is defamatory made up
nonsense
and Trump again is borrowing this line
of attack from left-wing groups that
already tried it against DeSantis during
a campaign that ended with DeSantis
utterly crushing the competition in a
landslide and flipping a bunch of blue
counties red and so Trump is seeing that
and saying well that line of attack
didn't work at all uh in a general
election so now I'm going to try it in a
primary so it didn't work in a general
election in fact a bunch of democrat
voters
found that line of attack so
unconvincing that they voted for the
Santa so now I'm going to try against
the Sanders with the Republican base and
see how it works out
it is um
not a great political strategy
you know we one thing about Trump is
that people have even as critics have
often in the past
um commended or if not commended at
least remarked upon Trump's great
political instincts but I mean recently
we're not seeing much evidence of that
and his whole approach to DeSantis this
is the approach of somebody with no
political instincts whatsoever
um it is politically it is the whole
thing is catastrophically stupid
and his attacks against the Sanders just
get dumber and weaker every time and it
looks desperate and As Trump continues
to obsess over to Santa's the Santa says
nothing in returns instead is governing
his State and it just makes Trump look
absolutely pathetic meanwhile also it it
and this is where Trump has to be
careful though you know the to say that
Trump should be careful there's no point
in saying it but
um
he he opens himself up
two lines of attack that yeah didn't
work against him in 2016 but there's a
difference in 2016 there wasn't anyone
in the race
with enough credibility with the base
to attack Trump on almost anything
you know he was Teflon Don in 2016. he's
not Teflon anymore there are lines of
attack that land and especially
and that can often depend on who is
launching the attack
the other thing about Trump is that
again 2016.
there was really nobody
going after Trump in the primaries from
his right
almost all the attacks were from the
left well they were about Trump is a
mean he's a jerk and like all of that is
kind of a version of a leftist attack
and most of it he's not civil he's not
it's like it's it's all kind of attacks
from from the left or from The Middle
um there was almost no one going after
him from the right
well DeSantis is to Trump's right
on everything I mean on every issue
DeSantis is firmly to Trump's right and
so and so if the sand is ever does
engage and eventually he's going to have
to if he does if he does run against
Trump if he actually gets into the race
um he's going to have some credibility
that none of these other people did so
the point is
certain line of attacks that didn't work
against Trump 2016 they may suddenly
become more effective
and so if Trump is bringing up
oh look at this look at this look at
this photo years ago if DeSantis
standing with some women
well that that it's pretty easy for
DeSantis to respond by saying oh really
well here's a photo of you standing with
Jeffrey Epstein and then a bunch of
other photos of you also standing with
Epstein
I mean if you want to bring this like if
you want to go there now does that mean
that Trump was you know that Trump was
guilty of anything just because he took
pictures Epstein took pictures with with
almost every prominent person
uh you know in in DC and in Hollywood
and all the rest of it so that in itself
doesn't prove anything
but the point is like if you're going to
go there
if you want to make wild insinuations
based on photos from years ago if you
want to go there then we can go there
but it's you are going to come out
looking worse a lot worse than me that
could be the Santa's response
yeah it didn't work in 2016. people
brought up the the Epstein pictures
didn't matter
I don't know if he could be so
sure that'll be the case this time
around I mean this is another mistake
that Trump is making is that he
and and a lot of his uh it seems like a
lot of people in this circle it's the
same deal they
they're convinced that that it's 2016
forever and that nothing ever changes
and so he could just do the exact same
thing he's doing in 2016 and it'll work
but it's not I mean times change and
these days they change very quickly and
political realities change very quickly
and so just because there could be
something that worked really well in
2016 and it falls flat now
um and Trump is not
kept up
so
and the biggest problem for Trump is
that
and I think this is what makes them so
insecure about DeSantis is that people
uh
people like DeSantis the Republicans
like the Sanders for what he's done and
what he's currently doing
you know that's that's why they they
like desantas
uh it's yeah they like the things that
he says and all that but that's very
secondary
that's not the points like we can see
what he's actually done while he's
governor and he's got and he's actually
put this stuff into action
and um that's hard to get around it's
like you you know you can't argue with
his results and and Trump really isn't
and he knows he can't so instead he's
he's he's kind of
around he's picking at the edges
and uh it it looks pathetic
all right
here's a great moment here
um in a BBC interview with Bill Gates
challenging him on his uh
environmentalist credentials listen to
this
what do you say to the charge that if
you are a climate change campaigner but
you also travel around the world in a
private jet you're a hypocrite
well I I buy the gold standard of
funding climb Works to do direct air
capture that far exceeds my family's
carbon footprint and I spend billions of
dollars on on climate Innovation so you
know should I stay at home and not come
to Kenya and learn about farming and
malaria
anyway I mean I'm I'm comfortable with
the idea that
not only am I
not part of the problem by paying for
the offsets but uh also through the
billions that my breakthrough Energy
Group
is spending that I'm part of the
solution
hmm
this is this is all uh this is all
science right this is the way that uh
that science works is that uh if you so
if you you know fly around a plane a lot
uh you you send a lot of carbon
emissions into the air you are changing
the weather
um you're causing hurricanes and
tornadoes and
uh even earthquakes I don't know if they
I don't know if they've tied that one in
yet to climate change but uh that's
that's the one natural disaster that I
think they haven't been able to get to
they haven't quite been able to to
explain how even earthquakes are our
fault but uh as far as I know they
haven't yet but eventually they'll
figure it out but anyway
you know you that's what happens when
you when you just live you live your
life as a as a modern person you're
causing all these weather events
um and these are all weather events that
existed before any of this modern
technology existed
uh but yet somehow now we cause them I
don't know yet you can
you can
erase your own impact by also as he says
if you spend a lot of money on climate
initiatives
so how so somehow the money
uh mitigates the carbon that you've
emitted
and so then you are no longer whereas
before you would have contributed to the
hurricane then the money comes in and it
wipes out that contribution and so
that's I I don't quite understand the
science I'm trying to understand this
but I'm sure that there is real science
behind this
I just it's probably it's of course it's
my this is what they would you know
they'd be quick to point out that it's
like my it's my problem just too stupid
to understand the science behind all
this
but Bill Gates understands the science
I mean why should we
trust him as an expert on climate
probably for the same reason we're
supposed to trust him as an expert on
vaccines and covid
because he's a really rich guy who's
been around for a while so it means he
knows everything
all right
here's another club I want to play for
Joy Joy Reed on MSNBC has her own
reaction to the Grammys where she's sort
of spiking the cultural football
um
and it's uh taking it in a different
direction from where a lot of our
compatriots on the left have done and
she says a few things here that that are
unintentionally kind of interesting so I
want to play this clip
I hadn't watched in years but I actually
really enjoyed it although I'm not sure
everybody else did it was to put it
mildly a celebration of the very thing
the American right has turned into its
latest anti-wokness Boogeyman diversity
equity and inclusion
the show opened with Puerto Rican singer
Bad Bunny singing 99 in Spanish then
host Trevor Noah walked and talked
through a room that was diversity equity
and inclusion in human form
the first country Americana artist to
perform
he walked so the room at the Grammys
he's also he's walking down in the room
with all the famous people that's
diversity equity and inclusion in uh in
incarnate that's what that's really so
it's a bunch of really rich Elite people
from the same socioeconomic uh with the
same socodynamic status the same kind of
cultural Stratosphere
um and who all believe the same things
and are are you know identical
ideologically that's diversity Equity
inclusion a bunch of Rich very rich
wealthy prominent
um
people who all agree with each other is
dive diversity and Equity inclusion
she's right actually that is that is
what Dei is all about it's just
interesting to hear her admit that but
was introduced by her wife and daughters
we saw the first trans artist when a
Grammy Kim Petras who has a hit song
with Sam Smith the British singer who
came out in 2019 as non-binary black
acting Superstar Viola Davis became an
egot winning a Grammy to add to her
Golden Globe Oscar and Tony Awards lizzo
performed with her amazing choir of many
sized singers
Beyonce took home her 30-second Grammy
to become the most Grammy decorated
singer of all time besting and I had to
look this up Hungarian British conductor
George salty
record of the year went to Harry Styles
a British male singer who frequently
puts on dresses to pose in magazines and
is a sex symbol to women and men because
of it
and there was a 15-minute epic tribute
to the 50th anniversary of hip-hop
so yeah the culture wars are over and
the left one like total defeat I Can
Only Imagine
hooting in red States I imagine Ron
DeSantis is somewhere stalking through
his Governor's Mansion trying to figure
out how to ban the Airing of the Grammys
in Florida and take away cbs's tax
exemptions no educational value queer
Theory black music
it's a helpful remote that despite the
almost external War the right is waging
to take the culture all right good so
you heard that now
a couple things here so as I said she's
she's sort of uh
spiking the football and say well you
see so the left one the culture one
okay well that's true
Joy then to begin with can you stop
acting persecuted
you just said you won
you won right and that means there's no
more systemic racism or sexism or any of
the rest of it because you won you won
the culture you took over
and and that's if if you want to take
the approach of bragging about it and
say you see we won
a fine I think that's actually a much
more honest approach
but then you can't in the very next
breath say and we're so we won we run
everything and we're persecuted
we're the Champions and we're oppressed
like you can't do that you have to you
have to choose a lane
so are you the football spiking Victors
are you you're dancing on the graves of
your Fallen enemies
are you that
as you portray here or are you uh uh
practically still you know in Chains
enslaved uh nothing's gotten better it's
it in fact it's gotten worse and you're
oppressed and so your your
intersectional you know you're black and
you're a female so you're oppressed in
many different ways with different
angles
which one it cannot be both Joy it can't
be both
so you have to choose
um
and I'll tell you which one is the
correct one it's it's it's well
it's sort of the first option that you
want it's sort of that
um
you did win
the institutions
so you're right you did you won the
institutions you claimed the
institutions
institutionally
it is an it's an all-out Victory as you
say
the Grammys are institutional they are
an Institutional award show it is the
it's the music industry is a billion
dollar industry a billion multi-billion
dollar institution awarding itself you
know congratulating itself
and
other people with institutional power
like yourself are are very interested in
the Grammys while while you know people
that do not have institutional power
just regular people look at this
spectacle and say like why should I care
about this at all
so that's what you want you won the
institutions
and from there you know the institutions
that have been all ideologically
captured every single one
from there the institutions are trying
to impose themselves and impose the
left-wing worldview on the population
and as far as that goes as far as the
population goes
you do have an enormous advantage
because you again you run all the
institutions that people need and people
rely on and and turn to and you control
the flow of information you control a
lot of stuff
and that gives you an enormous Advantage
when it comes to
capturing the people's minds and hearts
as well but it has not been an all-out
Victory there not quite
even with this advantage
and um
it it especially on some of the more
recent efforts
you know so like institutionally
you can we
can give an award to uh two biological
males and claim that there's something
other than male and so therefore this is
a great victory for diversity or
whatever and the institutions will give
that award and other people within the
institutions will applaud that and say
isn't that so beautiful such a wonderful
thing
but regular people
most of them they look at that they're
not so convinced
they look at you know chubby Sam Smith
and and we're told that he's well you
know he's not a male he's non-binary
what what is that
that's what regular people say they're
they're not convinced
and even though there are potentially
incredible consequences for not for
failing to be convinced like we're
punished for not being convinced and
still
most people aren't
and most people also are certainly not
convinced
that Tim Petrus who now calls himself
Kim Petras is actually a woman
because uh he was mutilated at the age
of 16.
the idea that mutilation makes a woman
or that his uh his perception of himself
as a woman makes him one
people aren't convinced by that either
so you do have the institutions
the question is whether you can capture
everyone's minds and souls from there
it's what you're trying to do
you haven't quite succeeded
and that's where the battle is going to
really be won or lost
but I'm glad we can agree again
that you are not oppressed
that you are in a position of power that
you own the institutions
that you are you you have now
um You Now claim incredible status and
privilege and power I'm glad you're
finally admitting that
so stop whining
let's get to the comment section
[Applause]
time I shoe says Matt was definitely a
Power Rangers kid growing up actually I
was not uh they were they were too
diverse for me
and I didn't like the diversity there's
a Media Matters you know you can't help
yourself you got to take that clip daily
wire host complains Power Rangers too
diverse
now actually I just I couldn't get into
the Power Rangers because uh it was it's
my you know the certain hipster uh
inclination maybe even as a
seven-year-old and they were too
mainstream really that was the problem
uh I was I was a hipster when it came to
my 90s Network TV Bargain Bin superhero
squads and that's why uh I liked VR
Troopers and a lot of you kids you don't
know anything about the VR Troopers
but they were because the Power Rangers
came along and then a whole bunch of
other shows that were just like exactly
the Power Rangers with a different name
and they kind of the you know you had
the Power Rangers which was the the the
maybe we'll call it the Target brand and
then you had the Walmart brand and you
had the Kmart brand VR Troopers were
maybe Walmart brand and there was uh was
it there was also there's something
called The Beetleborgs I wanted I think
that existed too where I just made that
up and that was maybe that was a Kmart
but anyway I was more into those I was
into the you know
was into the ones that didn't have quite
the same following
uh all right
cocktails and console says Disney Disney
slaves made this country well slaves
also make Disney's crappy merchandise in
China very good point should have
brought that up myself
um ha nokri says I disagree with Matt
about the young boys beating a
nine-year-old girl of course it looked
and was Savage but in society where boys
are thought they're toxic uh that girls
are better that they can humiliate you
and hit you without being hit back you
can expect these things to be happening
more and more it's not justifying but a
possible explanation why it did happen
um I didn't even say he doesn't justify
it but I think the only reason you say
that is if not to justify you are
mitigating you know it does appear to me
that you're at least slightly trying to
mitigate this and I'll be the first to
say that this message of toxic
masculinity is very harmful to men and
to boys and much of what you said there
I agree with but that that does not
apply
when a nine-year-old girl is being
viciously beaten none of that applies
this is uh
you know this is surely a matter of
parenting
I mean we
that that could happen in a world in a
culture that's very encouraging and
uplifting and empowering to boys that
could still happen
if a boy is is growing up in a home of
where there's just emotional and
spiritual chaos and he's he's being he's
totally deprived of any kind of moral
formation and his dad is not present his
dad is either not present because he's
not physically present he's actually
gone or he's uh at the very least not
emotionally and spiritually morally
present in the home and uh and that's
what leads to situations like what we
saw
Mike says Matt I'm a father of nine a
nine-year-old myself and if that was my
daughter I'd be in prison and that
teenage boy would be in the hospital if
he's lucky
yeah a lot of comments like this and I
have a nine-year-old daughter too and I
can't you know you see things like this
you can't help but imagine uh your own
child in in a situation like that and um
what I would want to do to that son of a
if I saw
someone treating my daughter that way
why I can't even say it out loud I it's
it's uh or at least I shouldn't um
what that kid certainly needs is for
someone to teach him a lesson a very
very harsh lesson in a very very tough
way
um and I just can't imagine I would be
I would be blind with rage I was pretty
much blind with rage seeing it when it
was not my own daughter and uh if it was
my daughter it at least I'd be able to
plead temporary insanity in court you
know I'd have that going for me
but
I I will say with that said you know I I
always think this when we see uh
videos like this and I
I hesitate
to go into the hole if that was my child
thing I hesitate
and uh and I don't know if this girl has
a father at home or not and that hasn't
been mentioned in any articles so she
might I have no idea
but assuming she does
um I think the
if that was my child I'd beat the hell
out of that kid some of that stuff even
though I agree with it and I mean I can
relate to it emotionally for sure
I think it can cast a kind of unfair
light on the actual parents of the
little girl
um
because the obvious sort of implication
even if we don't mean it this way is
that well we would beat that punk to a
pulp because we love our daughters
and so if that punk does not get beaten
to a pulp then I guess her parents don't
love her that much
you know
that to me seems to be the implication
and
so that's why I don't like the sex I
think I think if I was I could also
imagine being in the parents position
and hearing all these people say oh that
was my kid here's what I would do and
you're not doing that and so now not
only has this horrible thing happened to
your daughter but now you've also got
these feelings of guilt and like you
you're less of a man because you're not
reacting that way but what I can also
realize is that if you're actually in
that it's one thing if if it's you're
talking theoretically but it actually
happens to your own child now you're in
that position
and yes of course you want to find that
kid and ring his neck but
you also realize because now this is a
reality for you that if you do that
you are going to go to prison
um you you will you'll go to prison for
that and and then you know now your
daughters already has the trauma of
being viciously beaten that way
and now you're adding the trauma of
being deprived of her father because
he's in prison and you're and and now
your wife loses her husband because he's
in prison
and
and why do you want to do that in the
first place you want to get this
Vengeance you know at least in part
because you're so angry and you want to
let your anger out which emotionally
makes sense but it so in service to your
own anger you're going to deprive your
family of a husband and a father
and so I can imagine that if you're
actually in that position you now you
have to really weigh those things and so
it would make a lot of sense to say like
I
I can't as much as I want to react that
way I can't do that to my I cannot add
insult to injury
to my kid
which
uh
is all to say this is the kind of
lose-lose situation that is created
in a in a in a country
um it's it's the consequence of living
in an unjust Society filled with with
animals who do monstrous things and are
not held accountable that's the
consequence you create these lose-lose
situations
and and you create a lot of victims and
victims families who end up feeling
terrible no matter what like no matter
what that happens to your daughter no
matter what you do from there you you
feel terrible because it happened to her
and you're left with guilt no matter
what no matter how you react maybe you
go after the kid you go to prison now
you feel guilty for that you don't you
feel guilty for that
it's a lose-lose which is why we should
have which is why the the institutions
that are supposed to be in charge of
enacting Justice should do it
for the sake of the victims and their
their families
to celebrate President's Day this year
the daily wire is launching our
president's for sale sale with 40 off
new annual memberships the big guy got
10 well we're going to give you 40 get
access to the world of daily wire plus
with Fearless documentaries gripping
movies Dennis prager's the master's
program and the entire library of Jordan
Peterson's work including uh new
productions like Exodus logos and
literacy and on marriage all available
to watch right now coming down the
pipeline to a TV or laptop near you new
episodes of Ben Shapiro's the search
Exodus part two our much anticipated DW
kids content and uh Pendragon later this
year to sweeten the deal like uh like
ice cream we also going to give you up
to 40 off select items in the daily wire
shop so you're getting a lot of stuff
take advantage of our president's for
sale sale today uh you know that he
would so just go to dailywire.com
subscribe to become a member today
that's dailywire.com subscribe now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
as promised I've saved any discussion of
the State of the Union for the end of
the show but perhaps um I also maybe
have skipped the subject entirely
because the reality is the state of the
union is an absurd monarchical pageant
designed in its current form to give the
president of the United States a chance
to deliver a campaign speech on
Primetime television on the taxpayers
dime and under the under false pretenses
it's a it's a show a spectacle
what the media has tried to turn into
the political equivalent of the Super
Bowl but it will never be the Super Bowl
because people care about the Super Bowl
and they remember it for more than a day
and it's a really good game people will
remember you know those games for longer
than that and talk about it for years
whereas nobody specifically remembers
the details of any State of the Union
Address at all even 30 minutes after it
concludes
because the address doesn't matter
certainly does nothing for the country
whatever is said during the speech could
just as easily be you know communicated
through a written statement from the
White House and most of it will be stump
speech red meat type stuff that we've
already heard a million times the
country's not at all helped by it by the
state of the union and even politically
it doesn't matter it doesn't succeed in
doing the one thing it is really
designed to do which is to give the
president a chance to boost his poll
numbers
it can't succeed in that because most
people aren't watching it and even the
ones who do watch it will forget nearly
every detail about it as soon as their
head hits the pillow that same night uh
once 24 hours have passed the speech may
as well have taken place a century ago
in some far-af place and delivered in a
foreign language for as long as far as
anyone's concerned
after a day at most not one person in
the country will remember anything that
was said
that includes in this case the president
himself who uh didn't know what he was
saying while he was saying it nobody did
in fact much of the speech consisted of
slur gibberish which the audience
applauded because they assumed that they
were supposed to applaud I guess just
based on context clues like this moment
for example
[Applause]
oh there's the standing ovation I have
no idea what uh Rory jobs are but
apparently there people there are people
out there who want to raise the cost of
them
don't worry though Biden will veto that
so don't be concerned he will make sure
that everyone can afford can afford rude
jobs
you will we will all get as many Ruby
jebs as we want
that's one promise that we can count on
Biden to keep
uh we'll have to count them to keep the
promise anyway because no one knows what
the promise is so we'll have to take his
word for it at other points Biden would
start randomly screaming for reasons
that weren't clear based on the context
autocracy has grown weaker not stronger
name me a world leader
who changed places with Xi Jinping name
me one
name me one
settle down this guy's had one too many
jobs
I mean who by the way who what world
leader would would trade places probably
most of them but but also why are you
yelling at us well I know why that's a
rhetorical question randomly screaming
not being able to regulate your volume
these are classic symptoms of
Alzheimer's and I don't say that as a
joke it's just like the reality the
president United States is senile and we
are watching him physically and mentally
Decay right in front of us if there's if
there is anything that could possibly
make the State of the Union memorable
that may be it
as for the actual content of the speech
itself to the extent that we can tell
what the content was supposed to be it
of course mostly consisted of lies and
misdirections like this part where Biden
pretends to stand up to Big Pharma
many things that we did are only now
coming to fruition
we said we were doing this and we said
we passed the law to do it but people
didn't know because the law didn't take
effect until January 1 of this year
we capped the cost of insulin at 35 a
month for seniors on Medicare
[Applause]
look there are millions of other
Americans
who do not or are not on Medicare
including 200 000 young people
with type 1 diabetes and in these
needless insulin to stay alive
let's finish the job this time let's cap
the cost events for everybody at 35
dollars
folks
the big Farmer's still going to do very
well I promise you all I promise you
they're going to do very well
so fact check actually Trump capped the
price of insulin and Biden shut down the
program when he came into office also as
a general principle no Democrat on the
national stage at least of all Biden
himself can pretend to be standing up
against big Pharma the Democrat Party
and big Pharma are joined at the hip I
mean they are they are a dynamic duo
they're madly in love with each other
they're the modern day Romeo and Juliet
let's not forget that by Administration
teamed up with the pharmaceutical
companies in an effort to force
Americans to have or or be injected with
one of big pharma's drugs the vaccine
so that was that's bite
and it's not just that the Democrats are
also funneling countless children into
the big Pharma wood chipper putting them
on chemical castration drugs and
hormones the Democrat Party works very
hard every day to increase big Farmer's
profits and to tighten their
Stranglehold on the American public
that's the truth that they hope you're
too stupid to notice but this posturing
against big Pharma was all part of what
was supposed to be the kind of
mainstream popular portion of the speech
problem is that the Democrats at this
point can't even pretend to hold
mainstream views for very long which is
why Biden was forced to dedicate a large
chunk of this section to some issues
that while perhaps popular also don't
exactly rise to the level of importance
that a prime time presidential address
would allegedly seem to call for like
this watch
we're going to ban surprise Resort fees
that hotels charge on their bill those
fees can cost up to 90 a night in hotels
that aren't even resorts
we the idea that cable internet and cell
phone companies can charge you 200 or
more if you decide to switch another
provider give me a break
service fees on tickets to cash sporting
events and make companies disclose all
the fees up front
and will prohibit Airlines from charging
fifty dollars round trip for family just
to be able to sit together
baggies fees are bad enough
Airlines can't treat your child like a
piece of baggage
now I'll admit that this part of the
speech did resonate with me personally
because Biden is simply listing a bunch
of oddly specific things that he finds
personally annoying and promising to ban
them and as fans of this show know that
is exactly how I would handle the State
of the Union If I Was President
you know it'd be exactly the same thing
and another thing I'm tired of sitting
at a table in the food court at the mall
where the table's a little wobbly
because one of the legs on the table is
loose we're gonna ban wobbly tables how
are you supposed to eat your chicken
teriyaki in peace when the table's
wobbling
speaking of which
those fast food Japanese places should
include free spring rolls with every
order I'm tired of paying extra for the
spring rolls
on my wobbly table
that's exactly what I would do as
president I mean exactly
and there are a lot of wobbly tables at
food courts it's really annoying
so Biden's never been more relatable to
me personally and yet even I must admit
that this is not really what the
President should be concerning himself
with in an address of this level of
alleged importance Americans are worried
about inflation they're worried about
being able to afford eggs at the grocery
store they're not sitting around
wallowing in despair over Resort fees
like no one is thinking about that in
fact many Americans can't afford to take
vacations anyway so baggage fees and
Resort fees are the last thing that
they're going to be worried about
finally once Biden had spent as long as
he could you know pretending to care
about things normal people care about or
even to know what normal people care
about he eventually got around to the
one thing that really matters to
Democrats as far as that goes everything
you need to know can be summed up in
this moment here watch
Congress must restore the right
that was taken away in Roe v Wade and
protect Roe v Wade
[Music]
the vice president and I are doing
everything
exact access to reproductive health care
and Safeguard patient safety but already
more than a dozen states are unfortunate
extreme abortion bans make no mistake
about it if Congress passes a national
ban I will veto it
another big Applause there that was by
far in a way the biggest Applause line
of the night I mean the room was was
dead for most of the speech until it
came time to celebrate the murder of
children you know that's what gets
Democrats really excited well they
really care about
from there Biden would call for the
passing of the equality act which
enshrines into federal law a man's right
to use the women's locker room imposes
trans ideology on the entire nation and
every institution these two things
together represent essentially the
Democrat party's entire agenda kill the
kids trans the kids
all the rest as far as they're concerned
are extraneous details
but we didn't need the State of the
Union to know that in fact we don't need
to stay the union for anything at all
I think that's the one thing we learned
yet again which is why this State of the
Union Address and all others past
present and future are today canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to members block
hope to see you there if not we'll talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you